كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخالستيا اخر
صاروخيه جديده اذا ليبيانغ هو التوتر اذا
الذي تشهده شبه الجزيره الكوريه حيث اعلنت
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخ باليسيا قال الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي ان الصاروخ قطع الف كيلو
متر قبل سقوطه في بحر اليابان ووفقا للجيش
الكوري الجنوبي فان صاروخ يمثل نوعا جديدا
من الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تعمل بالوقود
الصلب
وقد رجح وزير الدفاع اليابانيه
سوكازوهامادا ان يكون الصاروخ الذي اطلقته
كوريا الشماليه من فئه الصواريخ
الباليستيه العابره للقارات واضاف ان
الصاروخ لم يسقط في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه لليابان
يعتقد ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا
باليسيا واحدا على الاقل في حدود السابعه
واثنتين دقيقه صباحا ويبدو ان المقذوف
عابر القارات اطلق من اليابسه بزاويه حاده
نحو الشرق وقد جزمنا بان الصاروخ لم يسقط
على اراضينا ولم يتاكد انه وقع ضمن حدود
منطقه البحريه الاقتصاديه الخالصه